i used to chase money a lot like how do
i make money maybe this will make us
money maybe this will make some money
and that was good because i like learned
skills about how to make money but
the things that actually paid off none
of those really paid off with a big
dollar amount
yeah i feel like i can rule the world
i know i could be what i want to i put
my law in it like no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back all right before we actually get
into the content
um a few things we've been making a ton
of changes to this podcast
the numbers are working i think the last
month was our highest ever right abreu
i believe so yeah so i think we should
start saying the numbers i think we
should start saying the numbers i think
we should
say what it is say what we're gonna do
and say what happens whether it works or
it doesn't
yeah so the trailing of 30 days was i
think 350 000 listens
um which if it's not the highest ever
it's one of like
one or two but the trajectory is is
really what matters and that is great so
we're getting around
an average episode i think is twenty
thousand downloads an episode
which is i think a sixty percent
increase from the year before is that
right abreu am i am i getting all these
yes twenty two to 23 000. right
so let's say we're at 22 000 uh
it used to be 15 of course it used to be
zero so you know whatever it's growing
and our goal is a hundred thousand per
episode one rose bowl stadium per
episode is what i want to be doing
something like that and uh so we're not
far 4x is you know
it's not far i think naturally that
would happen in a couple years
and what we're going to do is just
accelerate it so it happens in one
yeah i feel quite confident that if we
do the same thing but more
it would happen with time but i don't
want to do that i'm impatient i want it
to happen immediately
so uh the changes we've made is we've
prepared more for every podcast
which i think is very clearly working
yes we now have these videos going
um which i also think is clearly working
and that it makes me feel good
is it driving downloads i don't actually
i'm not convinced but
it's worth it you know what it does do
is there's a whole group of people that
like either a just don't listen to
podcasts or don't listen much so they're
like kind of like otherwise they would
only hop in once in a while
they didn't build a habit with us and
they follow just through the clip so
there's actually just like another
audience that's like oh good
i watch those clips every time because
they're good and i always get messages
i am yeah and i'm in that category as
well i've never i don't think i've ever
listened to a joe rogan podcast but i
watch
a lot of clips right um and uh we're
putting our clips on youtube
which is not working that is not working
well at all for us
right um maybe the we're putting the
full episodes on and a handful have 20
to 30
000 views maybe even more a couple of
them have a few more
that's working but the clips are not
working and then we're doing email
blasts and the hustle i think that
started two weeks ago
that is working we should we should
rewind we should basically say we had a
meeting
which was like a few i don't know week
ago maybe something like that and i was
like oh okay we got all these ideas
basically i threw in a few ideas you had
a few ideas bray who had a few ideas my
buddy ben had a few ideas
we were like oh yeah great all these
sound good so like who's gonna do them
and then we kind of had this like come
to jesus moment where it was like look
in sam we trust like if and we can't we
can't outsource this to somebody else
who doesn't
really i don't want to say it doesn't
care but like it's a different thing
when it's
your baby it's your show you are getting
the like
the more people who listen to this the
cooler opportunities we get the better
dms we get every morning
and so like clearly it matters more to
us than it would be for even if it was
somebody's
full-time job and uh the second thing is
like your skill level is super high
right like we saw you grow the hustle i
saw you grow the hustle
a lot of people who were subscribers saw
you grow the hustle saw you go trends
from scratch
and saw you sell the thing and it's like
so i got excited because i was like i'm
gonna get to see sam in action
even closer than i did with the hustle
where like you would send a monthly
update
now i'm seeing how you actually operate
and it's pretty
dope and i actually think the listeners
will like to see how you operate how you
approach
growing a thing and uh that i think
that'll be exciting
that's a lot of pressure thank you for
the compliment that's a lot of pressure
i
i will say i think growing the podcast
has been i mean that's actually
one of the harder things i've done yeah
but uh
hubspot owns us now it's not my money
like it's their money
and and so we're in a totally i mean
we're
our owner you know the company this
company now does a billion a year in
revenue there's like a billion
plus in cash in the bank account like so
we can actually
so we're gonna have a lot more resources
i actually am not convinced that that's
actually gonna help us grow that yeah i
don't think resources helps you grow but
i think i i would say like that wasn't
the problem before
uh it could be helpful but that wasn't
necessarily the problem and then
so what we're doing now is uh we don't
have ads in the email anymore so in the
hustle we do zero advertisements and the
podcast is going in every day now
um or not every day but a lot
and then also what we are launching at
hubspot and the hustle is we're creating
this thing
well i actually don't know if i could
say too much about it but there's going
to be a lot more podcasts
and amongst those podcasts we can
promote one another
and that's what you're going to hear so
whoever is in our pot our podcast
crew we're going to promote them them us
yadda yadda and i actually think that's
going to help a ton
i think that um i actually don't think i
could talk
any and it's pretty dope who's in that
but we'll say it later
when you can so okay can i give the
audience the five ideas that we had
brainstormed that were like oh okay
once thing one was like let's put sam in
charge of it because sam knows how to
grow [__] that was step one
step two okay so what are the like how
would you grow a podcast if you're gonna
grow a podcast
so we said i'm gonna rattle off the
ideas number one
big name guests that actually have an
overlapping audience so people like
chamath
people like tim ferriss uh not just like
a famous person who
like for example we had jake paul on uh
super famous but his audience is in our
audience not gonna have a huge amount of
overlap where
it's not necessarily that his fans would
would connect with us and become
you know ongoing subscribers um okay the
other one was paid
can you advertise to grow a podcast
right like running some experiments on
take a few thousand bucks run it on a
paid campaign and see can you grow
through
through paid i think we'll find out
that's interesting we're doing so we
bought ads in uh player fm abreu is that
what we did
yep yep and then um we're buying ads and
a few more
i have a few more that we're buying ads
did that work uh i bring you player fm
it's hard to tell because they claim a
lot of their views come from desktop
listeners
um which doesn't necessarily get
measured according to them um
oh that's like saying like thank you
yeah yeah it's like
like no look the it's like this is like
selling like cbd treats for dogs like
does it work
right can't ask your dog yeah
it was like the greatest business ever
it's like selling vitamin b
for your puppy uh yeah exactly
so i would say if it's hard to tell it
didn't work
it's a very obvious way to think about
it um okay
another one go on other people's
podcasts so do a do a tour going on
other people's pods they already have an
audience those people listen they say
oh man what a great guy i'd love to
listen to more of this person they were
interesting
boom get some people from there clips uh
people have seen we tripled down on
clips we found
awesome clip makers we're making [__]
up eclipse and we're gonna post the [__]
out of them so i think that's a good
good strategy
um there's the and then the last one
that i thought was kind of an
interesting one was like
get sharper on the branding so if you
want to grow a product
the sharper the hook of what is the
product uh
the better chance you have to grow
because it'll be more clear it'll
resonate with more people and so being
able to describe it well
as well as just being like on brand all
the time about like what this is and
what you get out of it if you listen to
it i think that's
an area that honestly kind of shitty at
which is ironic because i think we're
pretty good at it
with our startups but we're pretty bad
at it with the podcast like
the name doesn't really make much sense
um the description i don't know
we don't have like we don't do an intro
when you join to like be like oh this is
the podcast where xyz happens
we don't have like a a highlight reel of
like you know
start here if you're if you're new to
the pod like go here this is the
onboarding episode you know
basically in a sense it kind of succeeds
a little bit in spite of itself
right um and and a lot of people say the
name doesn't really matter
or sorry the name doesn't reflect it and
i'm in my opinion towards just names is
it doesn't your name
really like it rarely will it hurt you
in some occasions it actually could help
you i think coinbase is like the perfect
name ever
right but uh even if coinbase was called
like
uh uh blue sky uh sunglasses i'm just
looking i'm just making [__] up that i'm
looking at um
it would work blue sky uh like it won't
work
it would have worked uh okay so uh
should we move on to coinbase actually
let's move on to coinbase so coinbase
went public today
and it's everything about it is
astounding
right um do you want to start i can read
off some of the kind of the numbers of
like just
how big is that business and then we can
talk about the returns of this inves
of the investment so how big is the
business so coinbase came out the public
now so now they released their numbers
their q1 numbers came out 56 million
users
um six million monthly active users
which is
i think more than e-trade had uh you
know like total i think e-trade had like
three million
uh like trade trader accounts or
whatever and so
this is kind of amazing to me that there
was more people on coinbase
um coinbase makes up 11 of the crypto
asset market in terms of how many assets
are stored on crypto
crypt uh on coinbase 335 billion
in trading volume okay here's the
interesting bits
uh 1.8 billion in revenue for the
quarter
um for the quarter for the quarter so
round up to two so about eight billion
ish in revenue
that's right annualized um 800 in net
income
off that off that 1.8 billion in revenue
so like 2.4 billion dollars annualize in
profit
right and uh and then yeah so basically
the coinbase goes
it lists publicly today it wasn't a it
wasn't an ipo as a direct listing where
you basically you know ipo is
you create some shares uh you issue new
shares to buyers
direct listing is you don't issue new
shares it's just people who have shares
can get you know like basically sell
some of their shares
so uh they listed they had about 114
million shares for sale
and uh it's up about 40 on day one so
the implied market cap as of right now
is about 110 billion so what i wanted to
know was
um there's this kind of uh phrase in the
startup investing world which is like
anytime there's a gold rush like some
new frontier new space
it can be hard to like pick the winner
it can be hard to like you know just
grab your shovel
dig and find the gold and there's a
thousand people looking for gold you
don't know where to dig it might be this
one might be that lot that
land you you know you don't know exactly
where the gold is so the foolproof
strategy in any gold rush
is what they call the pixel shovel
strategy meaning you
you sell the shovels to people who are
going gonna go mine to gold and so
coinbase is kind of a classic picks and
shovels thing in the crypto market
so you you could buy bitcoin you could
buy ethereum you could buy one
you could buy litecoin or dogecoin or
one of the thousand altcoins that exist
and you're betting okay maybe one of
these will become like the digital
currency
um or you could buy a coinbase in
exchange that's going to trade
a bulk you know a bulk number of these
coins and so
i wanted to know once coinbase got up to
where it was like
100 billion valuation i had the question
of
what would have been a better investment
coinbase at its seed round
or bitcoin that same day if you could
should you have bought the currency
or should you have invested in the
company and the reason i thought this
was interesting is i remember
2013 i was i just kind of heard about
crypto from a guy in my office like our
pete our rit guy was like
dude bitcoin is the [__] it's at seven
dollars now it's at 11
i was like i don't know what that means
and he was like yeah [__] fiat currency
and i was like fiat i think that was a
car i didn't even know
that's a currency at the time i didn't
know what that meant um
and he was like mining bitcoin using our
servers at the office
and he's like we mined two bitcoin today
and i was like okay good for you pete
like what does that
do you know i was kind of like you know
mocking it but i was curious also so i
started going to listening to some talks
and uh
and so one of the things i was looking
at was like are are smart vcs are people
smarter than me investing in this space
and what i remember happening was i
listened to this talk and it was
andreessen horowitz was mark andreessen
uh who now blocks me on twitter um he
was talking at a thing he's talking
about how crypto's gonna be great how
it's how bitcoin is gonna you know
is such a interesting technology how uh
blockchains might change everything and
then the interviewer was like so how
many investments how much money have you
put into this you're kind of hyping it
up like
how much money have you invested and
like we haven't invested in any crypto
companies yet
uh this is like i think 2012 20 i think
it's 2012 and he goes
right now we're just owning the currency
we're just buying bitcoin
and i was like what that's so weird
these guys like
they're they're a vc fund they bet on
companies there's a few companies out
there like
i found it to be super strange because
right now the bet we don't know which of
these companies is going to emerge as
the winner
so we're just buying the underlying tech
the underlying currency we actually
think that's the right move right now
and uh and later you know andrews
norwood has actually did invest in
coinbase later
and uh since invested many projects and
actually
andreas horowitz changed their whole
fund structure from a private you know
vc fund to like
some other kind of like financial
investment vehicle they went and got
registered with like the sec or whatever
because they wanted to own crypto assets
and you couldn't do that out of a
traditional fund they couldn't you
couldn't
buy currencies out of a traditional fund
the paperwork the docs don't let you
and so um so anyways i went back and
looked at the numbers so
coinbase announces seed round september
2012.
um i don't know they probably raised it
a little bit before that and then they
announced it they raised 600 000
from investors including a crowdfunding
campaign which i which i found
interesting because
i don't like them i [__] on crowdfunding
all the time as like me too it's always
the bottom of the barrel but this was
through funders club
funders club had put in like 285
thousand dollars through its
crowdfunding into that
and so anyway what is is fun and funders
club is just a startup like
underscore itself is a yc startup and
then coinbase was a yc startup and so
funders club took a took a share uh like
did it did a crowdfunding campaign for
for that
uh if i read this correctly i i could be
wrong in this part but anyways
i went and asked one of the seed
investors so somebody who
uh a friend uh who invested in the seed
round of coinbase i said
what was the valuation back then he said
it was 15 cents a share
so 15 cents a share there and he said
the a round was only 20 cents a share so
it wasn't even that much more
um something like that so so 15 cents a
share
and um now it's trading right now
like right before this podcast at 330 a
share or whatever
and so you got this uh you know 2000 x
markup i think 2200 x markup
and um so you invested a hundred
thousand dollars in the in the seed
round of coinbase
that's worth 220 million dollars on this
day today
because it goes it goes public now if
you would invest in bitcoin same time
bitcoin at in that same month was
trading at twelve dollars a coin
now it's at sixty two thousand dollars a
coin so
your same hundred k instead you know
would have been worth five hundred
million dollars so still
bitcoin was the better investment even
though this was like a
you know you invest in a startup that's
became a 110 billion dollar company
still bitcoin outperformed but uh it's
closer than i would have thought because
coinbase has really
gone up in value in the last two years
so let's give some more numbers
um i think right before we started the
valuation was
80 billion but a few hours ago it was a
hundred billion right we're gonna use a
hundred billion because
that math is a little easier um brian
armstrong is the ceo he's 38 years old
he owns i think
twenty percent of the company uh which
means
uh a hundred billion his net worth is 20
billion dollars which
puts him i think like in the top 50
richest people in the world at 38.
uh the company coinbase i let's see it
started when
12 so it's uh nine years old uh so
basically became the
from zero to richest uh top fifty
richest people in the world in
only uh ten ish years nine years and
also
he owns twenty percent of coinbase who
knows how much i don't
know i certainly don't know but you have
to ask
how much bitcoin does this does this
person own if you told me
that it was another 20 billion i don't
think i would be surprised
at all do you would you be surprised 20
billion is a lot
that is that is a that is a very very
large amount
so i don't think it would be quite so
high but i wouldn't be surprised if
if it was over a billion dollars i think
20 billion would be 20 billion would be
like
he'd be one of the the top three i think
bitcoin whales i think
at 20 billion or something like that
yeah okay okay so i think that'd be way
too much
would you think i i i i don't i didn't
do the math ahead of time but
would you think you would be a top 50
bitcoin holder that seems reasonable
right it's plausible yeah
so i don't know we you know he i don't
think he's ever said or disclosed you
know if he
if he was buying the underlying coins
though so the biggest thing is did you
hold right because
bitcoin on this run up right so from
when you know if if
he's doing coinbase bitcoin's at ten
dollars a coin right
that becomes your kind of like frame of
reference bitcoin today is trading at 63
63 000 from 12 is such a like
mind-boggling
like change and so when i was talking to
the
my friend who was an investor in
coinbase i said i was like wow
did that did that mean does that mean
that coinbase outperformed bitcoin he
goes no i think bitcoin still wins
he goes but name one person who held all
their bitcoin from 2012 to 2021.
he's like sam's racing well
i guess like of people who owned a lot
of it at that time no i didn't i didn't
own a lot i owned
i bought hundreds of dollars worth but
no not a lot so let's say you owned a
lot you know
as that nest egg becomes 10 million 20
million 100 million dollars
you're gonna like a lot of people would
would liquidate some of it and so he was
saying you know all of us at coinbase we
really couldn't sell
this whole way and he goes the
illiquidity was a feature not a bug
like the fact that we couldn't sell this
whole time for coinbase
it was the best money making strategy
for us to like not be able to be liquid
until now
i didn't sell but my numbers were like
tens of thousands or maybe hundreds of
thousands of dollars right it certainly
was not
a million or tens of millions but uh i i
didn't sell because i actually forgot my
password
and i was like uh i just don't want to
log in because it's too hard
and so i didn't log in have you stopped
you have it now or no
yeah i have it now like i had i had uh i
just never did like a forgot your
password thing in my email because i was
like
too much work maybe it's a sign i'm just
not going to sell right
um and so i didn't sell but can what do
you have in front of you are you looking
at something i'm looking at this tweet
you put in
of chances i want to bring i want to
bring this up yeah so
um the numbers here is fascinating
but i actually don't think that's the
really fascinating part what's the
fascinating part is the psychology
behind this because
today's coinbase in 20 years it's going
to be something else
uh 50 years ago it was real estate or
something
100 years ago it was oil there's always
something yeah and
the psychology behind the human being i
think is far more interesting and by the
way
he was an engineer at airbnb before he
left to go start coinbase
his airbnb shares from you know would
have done amazingly as well right like
while he only worked at airbnb i think
for a year and before that he worked at
deloitte so i'm almost positive
granted he was probably a genius
probably like you know crazy high iq
but like normal guy uh normal like a
normal nine to five
um and also uh so let's talk about the
let's talk about the personality part
here that i love
um i like knowing what drives people
what makes them tick we talk about
billionaire of the week and it's not
actually about necessarily the money but
what
what what what do people think who
achieve greatness right in this case
it's money but reality greatness can be
a variety of things um so daniel gross
is the guy we have in this podcast he
went
uh so hacker news if you guys don't know
what hacker news is you should read it
every single day it's basically
uh reddit but only for nerds i love it i
read it every day it's uh
tech folks um and anyway um brian
armstrong has a handle
on tech news or on hacker news and you
could read his old posts and he has this
ol and daniel gross uh tweeted out some
of this guy's old post
his handle uh is uh i actually don't
know what his handle is but
well it's sorry it's b armstrong and so
b armstrong
actually had a blog listen to his blog
and this is actually kind of funny it's
called
start breaking free.com which is which
is kind of
on right on brand consistently and
actually if you go to
startbrakingfree.com
it's controlled by a virus so
it like they it automatically wants you
to install a
it's controlled by a virus or you know
what i mean
like are you like it's like if i go to
right now it's gonna try to install like
you know security software that actually
he's gonna steal all my money yeah just
do it
yeah well it's gonna say like you won
you know
you're the lucky winner uh like somehow
he let the domain expire or something
like that and
uh someone got a hold of it so now it's
just a scam which is kind of funny
uh that the guy who's supposed to be
like mr security his
web his domain expired and uh yeah
whatever
but anyway you can see his post history
and he was launching a lot of stuff he
launched this one thing and it says hey
hacker news i just built a new forum
software
hey hacker news i just built a new photo
sharing website
so the guy was really prolific and it's
really interesting to see his posts
yeah he was definitely like trying uh
like what daniel
tweeted out was i you know i look back
at brian's hacker new submissions before
he started coinbase
you can see what you see is a story of a
hacker working on different projects
slowly zeroing in on his launch
coordinates uh
right because he's consistently shipping
stuff they're not all like you know some
of them have like
one up vote seven up votes 32 comments
right like
they're not like taking off so you see a
guy taking a bunch of swings
and as his swings you could see it was
you know like something about maps
something about could you know how would
you start your own country something
about like
could you build an entire web app in one
language and then it's like
bitcoin android release um you know like
how airbnb does x and then it's about
you know like how to build your own
forum uh bitcoin iphone app and
you know just like sort of finding
finding like the thing that is his thing
and this is this is the true for
everybody right like you know people
joke about
sam's uh you know sam's foot long
wieners or whatever your hot dog stand
yeah you know my sushi restaurant it's
like if you dig back
into people's first projects um you're
always gonna find interesting things
like mark zuckerberg first project that
uh i've heard him talk about have you
heard this the dentist office thing
no he set up an internal like just net
internet network for his dad's dental
office
so it's like a messaging like the
secretary of the front desk could
message
him and his office uh you know in the
back so he just like kind of set up the
internet inside their office and let
them message each other
then he built wire hog you know oh and
wirehog i think was really successful by
the way
well for like a 17 year old kid for yeah
exactly 417
it was more successful and there's chat
transcripts of when he
after he like leaves to go work on
facebook he moves
you know in the social network they
moved to palo alto it's like
this is it facebook's gonna be the thing
there's chat transcripts of him talking
at that time like
yeah like i think wirehog's the thing
um you know like so even then it's not
obvious at that time
and whereas people try to project that
these guys are visionaries
they are you know visionary geniuses who
never had a doubt in their mind
and then they saw the future and then
they built it and it's like well
well i actually think that a couple of
those things are true
they could be visionary geniuses or
rather they could be geniuses
but that's actually not a prerequisite
but it does help but
they definitely had doubt regardless of
how confident someone is it doesn't
matter if you're conor mcgregor and
you're going in a fight you
always have doubt no matter what um and
second
um they probably didn't have a vision
until it started getting a little bit of
traction
right um i go back through there's these
there's this uh interview on youtube of
mark
uh doing there's like some college news
station that's interviewing him some guy
some
some guy has like a college podcast and
he invites mark zuckerberg on because
he's got
the college social network that's kind
of like taking off on a handful of
colleges i think they're on like
i don't know five or ten campuses at the
time and he's like
you know so what what is this going to
be you're going to go out to more
colleges and then what like high schools
and then
you know non-college students and mark's
like we're sitting there in his
like basketball shorts um with a red
solo cup in his hand
and he's like i don't know like i don't
know if it has to do that like
why can't this just be like the cool
thing for colleges like once you take it
out of the college thing then you let
everybody in it's like less cool like
maybe this is just cool and like now
he's literally putting [__]
satellites into the sky to give people
in india the internet so that they can
use facebook
like yeah so the aspirations changed
the takeaway here and i actually just
went back to my high school the other
day to like give like a talk and i was
like dude doesn't it you guys
look small when you walk into high
school yeah and you meet a 16 year old
and you're like oh my gosh like i
felt i was mature i felt i knew what i
was doing you're a child yeah i could
beat you up
yeah i'm like i was like dude i'm 30
and i thought that we were more similar
but we're not we're not at all
yeah yeah we're not like why are these
children low to the ground
yeah everything is so small and like
water fountains are disgusting i can't
believe i used to drink from them
anyway um i was like you guys
just do [__] take swings tinker on stuff
first of all a lot of stuff that starts
out cool it actually looked really dumb
early on but even if it stays dumb just
get into the habit
of taking swings and making stuff
because
uh like i'm not like uber successful but
my first [__] was like a poison ivy
business it was
my first stuff was like stupid and like
it led to this thing and this thing
and like hopefully the thing that i'm
doing now is actually going to lead to
something even bigger
and i also did a ton of research and i
found out that there is this poison ivy
treatment called
zanful z-a-n-f
i think zandful and basically i did
a ton of research and i found the guy
who started it used to work at a
cleaning supplies company and i was like
oh that's interesting what is going on
here like that's kind of weird that
i just saw that connection and i did
research and i found out that basically
what he did was he took this thing
called
i think it was called mean green and it
was really good at washing
um oil off mechanics hands and it costs
like five dollars for a gallon it was
dirt cheap
but he found out that uh the way poison
ivy works is if
if leave gets on you or if it leave it's
on you it gets this oil on you and you
have to use this oil stuff
uh this oil remover yeah yeah same thing
with poison oak or whatever
yeah yeah same thing and i was like oh
so i'm just gonna bulk buy this
mean green crap and repackage it and
sell it for forty dollars as opposed to
i sold it for like forty dollars for
like some like a
like a carmex size or like a you know
like a like a chapstick size thing
when it costs like 40 for like literally
an industrial sized barrel and i just
repackage it and i was making thousands
of dollars a month and then i quit doing
it because i was like
i don't want to do this anyway it was
kind of a cool thing
but i shut it down because i was like
all right this is making money but like
i don't want to do this i'm not proud of
this this isn't like anything i
i like to talk to tell people i'm doing
it's kind of lame even though i was
making like five grand a month
shut it down and um the point is
the thing that we're doing now i have a
feeling it's gonna lead to something
even bigger
and uh in in coinbase's regard
everything was much bigger in a much
shorter time frame but
uh it doesn't matter it's the the
exercise i think is still true
that's great uh you know those guys who
came and set up uh my studio here
they just released a vlog on his channel
this guy henry i forgot his nasty
henry blancaster or something like that
i don't know what it is but
basically i don't know how you'll find
them henry uh
on youtube he did this thing he put out
a video yesterday being like oh the
advice that i got from sean poury and i
was like okay well
i'm one of his like i don't know 100
subscribers like i'll click this this is
about me so i will go ahead and watch
this video
and his videos are actually super well
made he's like yeah very casey
neistatish like
any casey neistat yeah yeah uh which
just shows how hard it is to win on
youtube like his quality is really high
but like no one gives a [__] because
it's just youtube there's a billion
things on there
hey as we said just give it some time
and just keep trying right
so so the advice and i was like i'm
curious what the advice was because they
came over and they were like doing all
the work and i'm just sort of standing
in the garage
with like a cup of coffee just like you
know just sort of like trying to be nice
i'm not helpful but i was like trying to
talk to them and i was like
and they're like you know hammering
things and i'm just like asking them
questions and giving them some kind of
like
well here's how i would do it if i was
you guys because i really
resonate with anybody who's like if
you're like 22-23
and then you you're smart but you chose
not to go the traditional path
and like that feels right but then you
also just get these like hunger pangs of
like doubt when it's like
[__] my friends actually have a salary
wait like i'm sleeping in a like
you know four of us are sleeping in this
one bedroom apartment and um
and so i started like i really like
empathize with that because that's where
i was and
uh like i just want to tell them what i
what i would tell myself which is like
dude you're doing the right thing here's
how you need to think about this though
don't like
don't worry uh hey you know here's how
here's how this is gonna play out
and what i told them was like look
honestly the best times of my life were
three of us living in a you know one
bedroom apartment my my co-founder and
my roommate lived in my closet
because he couldn't even afford our dirt
cheap rent so trevor lived in my closet
and like turned my living closet into
like a room for himself with a lava lamp
and [__]
and then like his girlfriend moved in
with him in the closet too oh my god
and so then uh i was like you know he
had a grocery cart because there's no he
didn't have a closet
because he was living in a closet so he
stole a shopping cart
rolled it into his closet and used that
as like his hamper his closet for
himself
and i just remember like like at the
time everything seemed so shitty it was
like oh this is the shitty version of
life
and now i'm like no that was the that
was the most fun time
because all we were doing every day was
just trying to figure [__] out trying
new different schemes and projects
we had no responsibilities no burn and
then we were just like party for fun
like on the side and so i just remember
thinking like now that i look back i'm
like that was the [__] that's what i was
trying to tell them i was like first of
all guys
this is the best so like uh like embrace
this part you're never going to get to
have this again with your friends like
you have right now it's it's so fun
embrace these five years i said the
second thing is like
i used to chase money a lot like how do
i make money maybe this will make us
money maybe this will make some money
and that was good because i like learned
skills about how to make money but
the things that actually paid off none
of those really paid off with a big
dollar amount
the things that paid off were like the
people i was meeting and like doing
projects with or learning from
like those relationships pay off big in
the end um
you know the learning of like building
skills around like i did my first ecom
project like you i was selling these
wristbands called fatbans.com and it was
just a
fat rip fat wristband that i like
noticed a bunch of kids were wearing on
on campus i thought oh wait maybe that's
a trend
let me try to sell those online you can
customize them and so um
those skills translated but the the
business did not and so what i told them
the advice that he put in the video
um that i didn't even realize i said was
like
you're 23 years old now like here's the
trick to this whole thing you're doing
the right thing every day you're just
making stuff you're trying stuff you're
making content
you're having a blast with your buddies
we're going to measure the scoreboard
when you're 30
not when you're 24. and it's like that
was the game changer like kind of like
advice i wish i had and that i gave them
maybe 35 or 40. right but basically it's
like
don't like you're planting seeds don't
go dig up that seed the next day and be
like [__] this didn't grow into a plant
like no
plant that seed water it enjoy it and
just say look i'm not trying to win the
whole game in one year
uh in a year and a half and like if my
if my friends who
took this banking job or consulting job
or are doing better than me
in 18 months like i don't need to feel
like i made a bad choice
like i'm making the right choice for me
and it's gonna like let's look at this
as a 10-year game and we can only
measure the score that like
the fourth quarter is 10 years from now
so that's the only time you can look at
the scoreboard really
and the seeds that you're planting at
least in my experience and i think in a
lot of my friend's experience
and it also seems like you for sure uh
is it's [__] it's [__] it's [__] it's
[__] and then suddenly it's like
oh my god it worked it hits yeah like
so it like it's [__] for the most of the
time and then finally it's like oh
okay now it's all happening your
learning goes in this like gradual curve
like your learning does go up every year
where you're like oh man last year i was
such a dummy
i didn't know [__] about [__] and now i
know better how i would do this and then
the same thing happens the next year and
the next year and the next year
but your results can kind of stay
flat-lined for like a decade almost for
like seven years
before it actually you know stops being
a flat line and just like curves up
rapidly so i wanted to continue talking
about this but i'm actually going to
save
my stuff that i have these notes here
i'm going to save that for the next time
because i don't want this episode to be
entirely this stuff although frankly i
love this stuff do you like this or not
yeah man i'm just soaking it all in okay
um
i like this stuff but sean you want to
move on you want to do the other thing
you want to do micro choir or do you
want to keep talking about this
uh i don't want to keep talking about
this i want to do either some great
micro car or some ideas
i want to do micro acquire and this is
an idea actually
but uh we at the hustle we worked with
this guy
and i never talked to him because um i
wasn't the one working on the project
but anyway
i just started hanging out with him
recently this guy named andrew
uh people call him gaz but his last name
was like gaznati or something how do you
know andrew
or something yeah guys ducky uh i think
they can just call him gaz
uh do you know andrew or do you know who
he is i did the like the minis back with
him so that's the only way i know him
just through dms i've never talked to
him
andrew is 32 i think um he
previously had a company that i think
was an agency and he told me that he
sold it for like tens of millions of
dollars so it was very very successful
but his new thing is incredibly
interesting it's called
microacquire i think it's just
microacquired.com that's right and
the premise is very simple uh he finds
people that want to
he that wants to sell their their
company and he just talks about it in a
newsletter it's basically like appsumo
or like
the hustle but a newsletter that just
sends out cool companies except what he
does is he makes you pay money to be
access
to to get access to it you only have to
pay 200 300
though and you get a year's access and
his numbers are pretty interesting and
keep in mind
andrew's actually the only employee so
no one works there
um and so as of today he's got 1500
subscribers paying
299 a year and that brings his revenue
to about 400
000 a year and i posted a chart of this
do you see the chart i posted
uh no i'm on his twitter because i was
looking for that because i know he posts
oh here it is yeah no i have the chart
so i posted it um and i'll he just sent
this to me so i guess i mean i said can
i share it
he builds in public so he he announces
the revenue publicly as part of his like
way of getting more traffic
so he's got 425 arr and look at that
chart yeah that's a pretty amazing chart
um
really all the growth happened like in
november december january february like
it just lasts like
four or five months yeah and it's pretty
interesting and i actually shared with
you if you scroll down a little bit more
i shared with you his
his vision but what this guy is building
uh i mean this is his vision we'll see
if he can pull it off
um is a different type of angel list so
basically he wants to disrupt investment
banking and he wants to make it easier
to buy
and sell companies and it's incredibly
fascinating so he wants or sorry not
disrupt angelus but kind of be like
angel listen
when you describe what it is so what it
is
you go on there if you want to buy a
small sas business so a small business
that makes recurring revenue through
subscription
and um and so that's the that's that's
the thing i browse
and the size are it ranges so it could
you could buy one for five thousand
dollars that's making
a hundred dollars a month of revenue or
something like that or zero dollars
revenue but it has users
so you could buy it for as low as like a
thousand or five thousand dollars you
could buy a business
and as high as there's a couple for like
single-digit millions of dollars
on on there maybe there's a few that are
outliers but that's like i would say the
sweet spot the range for these things
are kind of like
hundreds of thousands of dollars is like
where the
you know decent businesses are on this
platform and this is the thing where i
talked about this once on the pod but
he had dm'd us and he was like hey like
love my first million
you guys are great would you know would
you guys want to do something with me
where i like
give away a 5 000 micro sas
business and i was like dude that's a
great idea i'll like go in with you and
like
i'll pump this to the audience and so
basically i tweeted out like i didn't
even talk to him i didn't actually
respond to his dm i just tweeted out hey
me and andrew are giving away
a sas business for five thousand dollars
like who wants it oh you know
all the business is there we'll buy it
and give it to you
it's like these are business that are
already working to some extent
you know uh it's like we just need to
add some hustle who's a hustler who
wants this business
and what ended up happening was a bunch
of other people started chiming in being
like i'm in for 5k
i'll put 5k in and so we ended up
raising a hundred thousand dollars as a
micro spec meaning a blank check company
so we raised a hundred thousand dollars
into an entity
to go and use that entity to go buy a
business off of micro micro
and then as of last week it closed so we
found an entrepreneur found a business
and we closed that deal to buy a shopify
app
that's amazing and that's pretty wild uh
i'll be eager to see what happens but
i'm sure you'll reveal in like six to
twelve months
um my opinion around micro acquire is
at worst it's gonna be okay right at
best it could be amazing
i don't know what it's gonna what's
gonna happen to it what do you think
it's a really fascinating business
and i the the thing is now i'm actually
shocked he's letting me talk about it
because i feel like i can clone this
so quickly uh yeah it's a lot of work
like i saw this guy doing the
the one deal we did and it was just like
[__] ton of work till this like
you know separate everything to make it
happen do the paperwork get a field yeah
but that's not the work for micro
acquire well
they have to help you do the transaction
so so that's their that's their function
um it's what's good is that they don't
make money on the like
transaction closing they make money on
you paying a premium subscription
like i pay a monthly fee to be able to
browse businesses
which is a much better model because
you're not just reliant on taking a
brokerage
fee of closed m a because there's just
not a lot of closed m
a that happens but there are a lot of
people who are curious and will pay the
you know 100 bucks or whatever it is 200
bucks to be able to like browse the
premium listings and get the
get the details get the info and so what
i would do if i was andrew is i would
decrease the price to 99
a year because that not or even 39
a year because that would make it an
impulse buy and i would get loads of
people
then i would do this company selling
then i would have a course that cost
two thousand five thousand dollars and
it would include a community and was all
focused on
buying and selling companies growing
businesses and i'm pretty
i'm pretty confident that you could get
that to around 30 40
50 million dollars a year in business i
don't know if that would be a valuable
company to
um sell but i'm pretty sure that you can
make 10 to 20 million dollars a year in
profit for
at least a handful of years i think
that's what i would i think it's needed
so i think it's smart that he
specializes in sas
i think that it's smart that he's a
curated marketplace versus
like flippa or these different places
where you're just like so much [__]
junk you don't know what
there's no trust so i think he's doing
it right that he's bringing trust to
these kind of like
lower trusts like marketplaces so i i'm
with you i really liked the project
and i'm with you that the minimum is a
good outcome
the maximum is like oh wow this was a
big idea hidden in plain sight
and um i'll i think it's interesting i
think it's more likely gonna just be the
good outcome but i like that it has the
you know the option to do both and it
seems like a fun
a fun kind of way to build if you're
this guy i think he wants it to be the
okay outcome which is
he owns it and he lives a really good
lifestyle right and uh
which by the way i think like i would
probably do the same as well yeah um
so anyway that's a cool company i wanted
to bring up what do you got uh
i got a couple okay so i'll go for
um we talked about this before but i'm
curious what you think so
um photo p uh we talked about this many
many months ago but
yeah we were much smaller than people
those people are probably not even
listening anymore
so we'll just pretend it's the first
time so there's this thing called photop
and all it is is it's photoshop but it's
free and it's in the browser you don't
have to download anything
and the guy who makes it i don't know
much about it he posts on reddit or you
know he he has posts on reddit it's a
pretty big thread
i think you know a little more about him
than i do with kind of like the
backstory but
it's a free version of photoshop that
has cloned every feature of photoshop
pretty much
it's like it's the exact ui of photoshop
which is crazy because photoshop is such
a complicated
piece of software to build and this guy
just chipped away just chipped away just
chipping away
and basically built photo p and p as in
uh like the vegetable like p-e-a and so
uh photop.com you go there and it's just
like one banner ad
that's like how he makes money i think i
think it does a million dollars a year
now
because so many people use this goddamn
thing like students and like people who
don't want to spend
photoshop's really expensive people who
don't want to buy photoshop
can use photo p and get like 80 to 90
of the same power without any of the
cost and without any of the headache of
downloading a big ass
one gigabyte application what uh
oh my god i'm on it so we do i know this
person is that what you're saying
i remember the first time we brought it
up you had already heard about it
because
i was like dude this i have a really
obscure thing and then you're like mr
obscure so you're like oh yeah
i've seen this on reddit uh at the time
i saw i remember being like shocked that
you knew about this thing because i
thought i
just discovered like uncovered gem you
know
yes i see it's from november 2018 uh a
guy
yes because it ha it got 50 000 upvotes
and he started it by saying i made a
free alternative to photoshop
ask me anything and that's how he got
promotion for it yeah i like this
um so you think he's making a million
dollars a year doing this
yeah so i i don't i don't know why ben
told me this
ben gave me this topic and he was like
photo p you know he's like you know
photo b was like yeah he's like you know
it's been a million dollars a year so if
i'm wrong ben's wrong
i didn't look at myself but um by the
way i got access
to similar web i've got a premium
account now bro you got the goods
yeah i uh someone who works at hubspot
uh i'll i don't know if i can blow up
their anyway i
got similar web dude i'm the same way
where at
twitch i was like oh dude you got a
premium app annie account that's like a
couple thousand books a year to see
app download stuff like share the login
and they're like you know we're like a
company you just buy a seat and it's
just the company pays for the seat
if you think you would use this just to
buy it i'm like oh my
like i felt like such a pirate like i
had to like hide i was like oh yeah of
course of course i wouldn't boot like
that like
well yeah that's not what i meant
that i'm still trying to like be a
little bit less hood rats him and more
like oh yeah
it's like this is roi positive just buy
it right right uh it's actually like
very much looked down upon to
be that way like i was negotiating with
somebody and they're like wait why are
you trying to like
why are you trying to like save us all
this money negotiating with this vendor
like just pay the
thing and do it up front and be like
but this goes against like everything in
my jeans i can't
not do it i was like yeah but it's in
the motel 6.
like i saved us at 200
i always used to tell people yeah like
i'll take care of your accommodation and
it was that they would actually be
sleeping in my stand on my aunt's house
and i would actually go i would stay at
my girlfriend's house and they would get
my bedroom
i did that all the time yeah we'll take
care of your accommodation
uh because we get hustle god they just
slept at my house
so according to similar web photo p gets
8.5 million
uh monthly uniques they spend a ton of
time on the website
and most all the traffic is direct so i
if you told me that this made a million
dollars i would think are you sure it's
not a million dollars a month
uh i don't know because i i got it i
gotta check i don't think it's a month i
think that would be
pretty pretty crazy i think i think a
year because you know he's only he's not
monetizing well right he's just got
display ads so
he's you know he's got the bottom of the
barrel monetization i think on the on
the site
yeah you could probably crush this
though um speaking of
just well go ahead well i was just going
to say like you know okay to
so what so i think there's so what here
is a photo piece cool and interesting
and like
just a cool thing to know about but b
like couldn't you do this for more
things like
first of all take the whole adobe suite
and
do the photo p for after effects do the
photo p for illustrator photo p4
for the whole suite right like anything
that has over x million users
um you could do this for what else like
maybe it's like
autocad like i don't know if that's free
or if you pay for it or whatever you
know like
uh i forgot like uh what's that thing
called math lab matlab or something like
that it's a thing that all the engineers
have to use
um like is matlab paid is you know great
can you
can you do this and i think a version of
this is
uh called obs so have you ever used obs
no what's that obs is an open source uh
piece of software that's basically the
most popular thing for every twitch
streamer or youtuber
so it's the easiest way to like stream
from a pc high quality video and audio
to twitch
to whatever so for years twitch actually
just until recently twitch didn't have
any way
if you went to twitch like great i want
to be a streamer they're like cool go go
use obs
what the hell is obs twitch doesn't have
a button just saying go live
and uh same thing with youtube you go
live on youtube nope can't just go live
on youtube with uh without like
using more sophisticated software and so
obs is actually an open source project
maintained by a small community
developer but really it's just one guy
jim
and i met this guy and jim's like you
know i don't know
five foot seven and like long hair down
to his kind of waist
and he looked like an open source you
know like app developer and he's like
extremely
high ethics and morals where he's just
like
the app is 100 free he's been working on
it for a decade
and it's supported by donations of
people who are like dude
i i run my whole business off obs like
sure here's ten dollars you know
and um and twitch twitch actually was
paying him every month
uh just to keep maintaining obs because
it was like cheaper to just pay jim
i don't know x thousands of dollars a
month than to like have 20 engineers
trying to recreate this thing
i think that that is cool i think that
like when i hear that i'm like that's
badass like i love that
that i love that that exists right but
what was my what was my thing earlier
i'm like
cornrows and sleeve tattoos i i respect
it and i think that's badass i just
don't want it it ain't for me i'm not
wearing it
uh and that's the that's my case with
this which is i'm so happy that that
exists
i ain't doing it because there's a bunch
of examples of this so another example
is spicework spiceworks.com
they were doing like 50 60 70 million
dollars a year in revenue and they ended
up selling
and because they raised too much money
it didn't work out but they had traction
and basically what what spikes or
spiceworks did was
they created uh software so if you're
like if you have like um
um a thousand employees and you wanted
to figure out which computers you needed
to buy
they created software to help you figure
that out which normally
costs money and they actually made money
through advertising on the website
in my opinion that's like neat
but just charge people money for your
thing
because i'd like would you rather be
photo p or adobe
uh yeah i know what's worse of course i
know which one i'd rather be
so i think it's cool to actually do that
free stuff just to get a ton of users
but after a while like if i was photo p
i would be like well if i just
i should just hire more engineers and we
should make some premium features
and up charge and that is what i would
do i would
not do this well there's another way of
looking at it which is
sometimes like free doesn't mean no
ambition so for example
skype was like hey free international
you know like calling
and whatsapp same thing why did whatsapp
take off because sms was actually
really expensive you had to pay for
every tax especially international
texting
it was super expensive so what's that
free was the growth hack
and for these guys i would say free is
also the growth hack but you know if
you're
if you want to just be one person
maintaining this thing and like whatever
like
you're where you do it matters so
photoshop is still at least big
but nowhere near as big as texting and
calling was right that was like such a
huge market
and then the second thing is like if
you're gonna do free
find some other way to capture a ton of
value so uh skype and whatsapp we're
able to capture a bunch of value
using a totally different method whereas
photo piece just like cool here's a
here's one banner ad
um you know and that's enough for me or
obs is like hey donate to me and that's
it
whereas obs could have like created you
know either premium features or sold to
twitch or you know
could have done many things to try to
capture more value out of the free thing
that they made
do you know the website unsplash so
unsplash is a
alternative to getty's images so getty's
images
uh everyone has probably heard that word
not a lot of people probably use it we
used it we paid them 50 grand a year and
we were a small client getty images they
pay
photographers they buy right why were
you paying so much
because there's cheaper or freer options
for photo libraries
gettys is the best um so a lot of
free or cheap ones they don't actually
have images of
of the people so for example if you want
to write about elon musk a lot of the
free ones don't have good pictures of
elon musk
second once you get to the size that we
were like we like which is not that big
once you get past like 500 000 monthly
uniques
you probably want to stop doing things
illegally when it comes to photos
because there's all these people that
yeah and which is like a
it's the right thing to do right you you
are using other people's stuff so you
shouldn't do it
it's okay to kind of bootleg it early on
but after a while you should pay for it
uh and we were a small person
we were and we paid i think 50 i forget
tens of thousands of dollars
and anyway there was this competitor
called unsplash
i think unsplash is dope i think they're
badass they're just acquired
acquired recently i got a little
information where
i like i found i heard a little bit
about what they were doing they were
only doing around
four ish million dollar five million
dollars a year in revenue
even though like hundreds of millions of
their images for being downloaded
right and i was actually shocked at how
small they were um if i had that much
traction a i would have been far more
aggressive about selling ads on the site
and be
far more aggressive about getting
subscriptions and charging a lot of
money for them
because this website unsplash which from
the outside appeared to be doing wildly
well
and i imagine they actually were
acquired for a lot of money because if a
proper person could get their hands on
that they could
crush it i would think but um if if you
have that much usage like unsplash [__]
unsplash wasn't ubiquitous but it was
quite popular you can make way more
money by charging money up front for all
that stuff when
unsplash giving away their stuff for
free i think they're only doing like
400 500 000 a month in revenue right
right right
uh okay yeah that's a good that's a good
example of one
i had one other topic i wanted to do um
okay which one's more interesting to you
is it the affirm for x or is it
game film for salespeople i'll let you
pick from those two categories
uh a firm and i have a i have a take on
there that you're not gonna like
oh okay good good all right so uh if you
don't know what a firm is a firm was a
company started by
um max levchin i think uh am i mixing
this up
right all right so max levchen the
co-founder of paypal
uh the firm went public i think this
year or last year it's
about 17 18 billion dollar company right
now and what a firm does
is when you're on an e-commerce site
you're going and you're buying a
mattress online
you go to casper's website and it'll be
like oh wow this mattress is twelve
hundred dollars
and it'll say or or for you know
96 easy payments of eight dollars
you can own this mattress right so it's
basically a pay-as-you-go
software that lets e-commerce stores
sell more stuff because
uh if people don't have the full amount
or don't or you know they're hesitant to
spend a large amount of money right now
you can offer them pay as you go plans
with a zero effort and then they take a
cut so
you know uh you know on on our ecommerce
store we offer we use one called sell
and sezzle will uh basically say great
you could buy this thing for you know
four payments or eight payments of ten
dollars instead of paying the full
amount right now
and um and then they take seven percent
and then they send us the rest of the
money
and so it's kind of a no-brainer as a
retailer because it just it really does
improve conversion
and for us customers were asking for it
because they were used to buying it and
it's up
it's it's publicly traded company now it
does really well
and so and there's several of these so
there's after pay in australia which is
even bigger after pays a 34 billion
dollar company which is kind of
interesting because
normally australian companies are much
much smaller uh klarna is like big in
europe i think for this
i think klarna is even bigger than all
of them exactly so karna's probably the
biggest one
and um so there's kind of this war going
on they're all trying to like
um like i think a firm partnered with
shopify so it's like built into shopify
now
uh that's a big move but basically okay
pay as you go interesting space
uh kind of was one of the big ideas that
just came out in the last like 10 years
and
is a good example of once it started
working in the u.s
it was not hard for people to just be
like cool we're gonna do we're gonna do
a firm for australia we're gonna do a
firm for the uk we're gonna do
a firm for india whatever right so i
think generically that was a good
business idea
what i thought was interesting is what
else could you use it for so i heard of
one company in this
uh this year's yc batch that was doing
pay as you go how did you get access to
that
bro big time investors like us that's
what we get access to
actually yc still has not accepted me
into the investor pool even though i've
invested in probably like 10 yc
companies at this point
um yes but but uh but i have a friend
who
gave access so so that's no problem um
so anyways
one of the companies uh what they do is
they're a firm for general contractors
so another high ticket item you're
getting you know your garage redone
or whatever bathroom remodeled or you're
building out you know a multi-family
apartment complex or whatever um they're
giving the general cut they what they
did is they went to the general
contractor just like
that's their version of the e-commerce
store and they say hey instead of
charging your client
12 grand for this you can just offer
them pay as you go and it helps your
clients pay you money
and you get a higher collection rate you
have less less
kind of late payments and defaults um
and higher conversion rate because
people can afford you this way
it makes you more affordable and uh they
were doing all right they had you know
decent revenue and
uh you know it was early still but i
thought oh this is interesting are
people going to do pay as you go
in more more industries more more
sectors and what else might be okay but
here's my tip here's my take klarna
after pay and affirm i like the people
who start them
i think they're horrible companies for
the world i think that they
you they should burn down completely and
not exist
i think that why because it's getting
people in debt it's getting people in
debt
it's making you buy stupid [__] that you
can't afford
so where like where's the firm like if
you go to like
fashion nova like people who can't
afford
who people who want to do a firm for a
pair of pants i'm like don't buy those
[__] pants
don't use a firm don't buy any of this
you don't need this [__]
don't buy it do not buy it run and also
if you're gonna have to buy it don't go
in debt to buy it i think this is
horrible
and i'm actually shocked at a guy like
max lipchin who i think is a cool dude
he started paypal he started all this
stuff that's badass like i seemed like a
nerd i love nerds
what are you doing this is useless
you're just you know you know just
started how he got the idea
tell me he was um so this is the version
of the story i know
i'm gonna be you know somebody who was
there probably knows a lot more details
but what i had heard was
there was an engineer who had uh so he
had this lab like i had monkey inferno
he had a lab called hvf
hard valuable fun and basically it was
an incubator where he said i'm gonna do
any project that satisfies those three
criteria it's gotta be hard it's gotta
be valuable it's gotta be fun
and so uh and then they kind of like
didn't have um like i think they've had
a few nice companies glow came out of
it's fertility tracker
and then a firm was the big one and max
like went all in and he became the ceo
of a firm and all that stuff
to take it forward but the origin story
from what i heard was
as an engineer who had come up with like
a new uh like database technology or
database technique
he's like oh look at this he's like
basically nerding out he's like look at
this we could do like so much
computation and so little time and like
with this new technique
and i was like okay but what are you
gonna use that for it's just kind of
like blockchain it's like great your
blockchain but like
why do we need a blockchain what are we
gonna use it for does it really make
this better
and like there's you need to define an
application so the way that blockchain
found
money currency as as the core killer app
uh what he what max realized was he came
into the this guy was an eir for him
so for months he was just like working
on this like databasing technology and
how he was going to use it
couldn't really figure out an
application and then one day max walks
in he goes
dude like credit scoring and credit
reporting
is so like ancient we should be able to
like
if you're a person today i should be
able to take signals from the internet
social social networking data uh
publicly available data on the internet
to do instant credit uh worthiness
versus like the way that this works
today with this kind of like
you go get a credit score and it's based
off of like you know stuff
in the past so his insight was
there has to be a better way to
determine the credit credit worthiness
of a person
and he's like your databasing technology
is actually perfect for
doing that on the fly and doing that at
scale and so they came together and he's
like great i'm gonna like basically
create this application to do this
and i think at first they didn't want to
do i don't think the initial very
initial idea was what they ended up
doing which was like pay as you go on
e-commerce websites but pretty quickly
they realized
that's the use case that's the market
that needs this the most
is basically instead of um
like i guess my question to you would be
do you also feel do you also use a visa
and mastercard like
because it's just credit cards that's
all this is it's just credit um
so do you also hate credit cards the
same way you hate pay as you go
you want to know what's funny is uh my
credit my personal credit card limit is
four thousand dollars
um so i've got a i've i've never had any
debt other i just got more are you one
of those people that uses debit cards
instead of credit
i do it because lately someone has
advised me to do it but for a long time
no but i'm not against credit uh and i
realize that what i'm saying is not
entirely logical it's definitely
emotionally
driven and you're saying and i'm not
like going this hardcore libertarian
route which is like
well i'm like against the government
therefore all government is bad i'm like
no no
no like i'm gonna draw so what i'm doing
right now is basically i'm drawing the
line right which i get
uh it's does that's not always the best
but i think that
credit cards in some cases are good and
affirm in most cases are bad
that's what i think okay i think that's
you know that's why
because the people like do you know
do you have any uh do you know like in
europe like our friend ramon and a lot
of my other uh
friends from europe they were like you
know credit cards we don't use credit
cards like in
germany yeah like in a lot of places in
europe if you
want to use also we use bidets proper
cleaning yeah
which by the way whenever people were
flipping out over covet and toilet paper
i'm like dude take a shower
like what the [__] you flip it out over
this why are you fighting over this
uh anyway um you're going to shower
every time you [__]
could be twice a day but like it's it's
the inconvenience is not bad enough that
i'm going to fight over that
that's fine that's right that's what i'm
saying i'm not going to like stab
someone and like
uh or i'll just be uncomfortable anyway
um
i just think like credit cards aren't
that common in europe uh there it's
definitely an american thing
but long story short i am not in favor
of a firm
uh i think that that is a stupid thing
to spend his life working on that's my
opinion
i would love for him if i could go to
him or bait him into coming on here and
convincing me of otherwise because i'm
open-minded but i think it's dumb i
think it's stupid
for general contractors that's a little
bit different but for buying like a 29
pair of pants like don't [__] buy the
pants well
i uh my family member trains his
daughter in jiu jitsu
and so maybe maybe we could use the the
daughter jiu jitsu connection to get max
on the pod
uh very soon uh am i wrong though do you
agree or disagree i disagree i disagree
completely i think credit is a great
thing
it helps the economy move i i'm always a
kind of don't hate the player hate the
game type of situation where
i put the burden on the individual in
the same way that i wasn't like oh my
god
jewel or like you know like is you know
is
is grey goose evil because it's alcohol
and alcohol causes problems no like i
don't think so i think it
i basically for myself i live my life or
i never blame
a company for tricking me into like
doing something i blame myself if i
don't have the self-control and the like
thought process to do it and so that's
how i look at others too
i will never blame a credit card company
for um
for somebody getting in debt now what i
do say is if you're
not transparent about what the fees are
what the charges are what the rates are
then that's shady right you're
withholding information you're not
disclosing you're hiding the fees
but um but in this case they don't
charge people more
uh for you know for buying a lot of the
times it's zero percent interest
actually
because they they can offer the
customers zero percent interest
because they take seven percent from the
merchant for helping them close the sale
and so it's actually an interesting
model compared to that's interesting i
didn't know i didn't know the full
depends on the credit worthiness like
when i i bought a eight sleep mattress
using a firm and i was like because i
was like oh do i want to spend like two
grand right now
oh i'll try this a firm thing and i was
like oh this is cool i can just pay in
payments and it's zero percent interest
because i had well i tried doing it i
also have a
sleep i tried doing it with there and i
actually was gonna have to pay like a
pretty hefty fee
i was like oh no because you don't use
credit cards you don't have high credit
something like for some reason i don't
have a good credit my credit score is is
not bad anymore but it was bad
uh because i didn't have history anyway
well i have one one last idea on this
which is
um i think this is the same thing as
like you probably know what layaway is i
don't even really fully understand what
layaway is layaway sounded like a total
scam to me
it's silly it's silly basically like
what it is if you want to buy
a 500 thing you would go each week and
you would give them a little bit of
money and would start paying down your
balance and then eventually you'd get
the item
right but it's crazy because like with a
firm you get the item first and then you
pay later
buy now pay later right that's that's
well you have to remember
there's a one big thing which is like is
that if
if it's gonna take you three months to
purchase and you can't if you don't have
the internet to buy stuff
like you want to guarantee that they're
gonna like that's yours
right i guess for me it's like our items
really out of stock but apparently
there's a huge thing like walmart like
in most parts of the country
layaway is like a huge part of their
business um and it's a it's a
it seems like a pretty predatory thing
in a way but i i don't know too much
about it so i shouldn't really speak on
it
but um anyways i guess my my point is
why
aren't people doing a firm for retail
stores so
why isn't this the same option every
time i check out you know
my wife goes and shops at i don't know
wherever you know nordstrom
like when she checks out they're like oh
you know do you want to open a nordstrom
card or whatever
why isn't it hey um you want to pay the
full amount today or would you like to
pay in installments
and you could pay an assault now maybe
this is already the case i don't know
but like it seems like something that
should be built into the point of sale
at retail stores i don't do a ton of
retail shopping so yeah
this might be me being dominant actually
is totally a thing does a firm plug into
shopify
yes and do a lot of people use shopify
too but like nordstrom doesn't use it
but like a coffee shop might
yeah not really they're trying to do
more that square is definitely trying to
do
a lot of like retail plus online
like you know brick and mortar and
online um so maybe square does it
but uh but i think a lot of retailers
just have their old school
pos still this is like one of those rare
topics that you're bringing up and i'm
like oh
i don't know like how do people buy
stuff at stores i've done it yeah
we should just smoothly exit this topic
before we uh
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back